(rock music begins)
(rock music continues)
- [Kelly] Oh, man,
it looks like we've lost Lester.
So, I told you, Jason,
this is what happens when
you play with spinal tap.
- It´s worth it.
- [Kelly] So now we've lost a drummer.
- [Jason] It's very worth it.
I'll give up the drummer and Jocko.
- [Kelly] Okay. Okay.
Well.
Okay.
- [Kelly] I mean, here's
my question, Derek.
How many drummers have you have you lost
in time in life?
- How many grains of sand
are there on the beach?
- [Kelly] Grains of sand?
No one.
Oh my God. Okay.
Well, any advice for
finding another drummer
since we're in need.
- I make more everyday.
(Kelly laughs)
- Such an easy job,
Lester´s not that talented.
Yeah.
- You just have to count to four.
- Alright, well, we've hit that time
when I get to pile on
one more moment of joy
before the show ends,
this is What I'm Liking.
(lively guitar music)
(crowd clapping)
- Before the break,
Emily helped me give away
some amazing vacations
to our rad moms.
But now I want to revisit a mom
that we gave a trip to last season.
Remember Jocelyn?
- [Kelly] Oh!
Where is it going to stop?
Where is it?
Hey! Okay.
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh my god, thank you.
Wait, what's your name?
Have you ever done RV traveling before?
- Oh my god, I´m going to cry.
My name is Jocelyn
and I've never done RV traveling.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, Jocelyn!
I love you right now,
and I kind of want to go
on your vacation with you.
You seem fun.
It was such an amazing reaction.
Since then, Jocelyn took
the family on their RV vacay
and they documented the whole thing
on their social media.
They started here in California,
hit Las Vegas,
then traveled to Colorado and toward Utah,
they did it all, y´all.
We have Jocelyn on the line to tell us
all about it.
She's watching on our partner station,
NBC for Los Angeles.
So Jocelyn, this was a
dream come true trip.
How was it?
- It was amazing!
We have two kids.
Jagger's nine and Penelope´s six.
And what's crazy is that
they've been begging us
to go on a camp truck or RV trip
ever since seeing the movie Toy Story 4,
because they go on an
RV trip in the movie.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So we were gone for two weeks,
which is the longest
vacation I've ever been on.
Those two weeks meant everything,
because we really connected as a family.
And Kelly, I just want
to thank you so much
for this opportunity.
We're so grateful.
- [Kelly] Oh man!
- You´ve gifted us with that trip.
- Thank you so much, Jocelyn.
I'm liking your posts right now,
and that's not all.
Usually this is the spot in our show
when our season long partner Pilot Pen,
they go to pen at the Kelly Clarkson Show
honors our final guests for the check
for a $1,000.
But,
since Jocelyn got to
enjoy the awesome trip,
we're going to give
another mom that check.
So let's find out who
it is in the audience.
Joe hit it!
(crowd screaming and clapping)
- Who is it?
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] I love it!
Wait, so what's your name?
- Dimitri. Oh my goodness.
- Dimitri!
Alright, well, Dimitri.
Pilot is using their G2 jelling pen
to write you a check for a $1,000.